hello friends I'm Ilana and welcome to
my channel with today I just wanted to
have a nice little chat I don't know if
you can hear the birds in the background
they're quite loud let's just say it
suits the tone of this video to have
birds chirp they stopped I swear to God
just thought I'd sit down have a nice
heart to heart just you and me and
everyone else who's watching this video
and I feel like it's been a really long
time since I made a video like this one
and hey maybe I only have like once or
twice before but sometimes it feels like
a thing I should do it's weird and not
necessary for everyone to watch but here
we are where to start though you know
we're how to begin
I got Expo I don't know if you can
really see it basically the pots of my
hands that look really red feel like
they're on fire but also it's all
peeling yeah I tweeted about this a few
weeks ago I was like my hands feel like
they're on fire for no reason and
they're bright red and it like tingles
what the hell has happened to me this is
so annoying because it's not a great
feeling naturally the whole of Twitter
diagnosed me with like cancer and toxic
shock syndrome and literally nobody said
ex-mo I had a friend who's Ian Hecox
actually who texted me and was like hey
could be this so your tweet
sorry about that so naturally I went to
the doctor went to a dermatologist they
were like yeah you totally have eczema
and I was like I've never had this
before in my life what has happened like
how have I just spawned
another illness because holy [ __ ] there
is a lot wrong with me so I was like how
did I how did I get this where did this
come from why do I now have a skin
condition along with all of the other
[ __ ] that I already have to deal with I
was kind of like you know what universe
I don't feel like I deserve this can you
give me a break who cursed me and why
and the doctor said that the reason is
most likely stress that you can develop
things like the specific kind of eczema
that I have due to stress he was like
did we you stressed a little austere and
I was like yeah tremendously not only
mentally like it was a tough year
mentally for a bunch of reasons but then
yeah the physical stuff as well it was
just a combination of like being
mentally stressed and physically
stressed that led me to
getting a new goddamn condition I
haven't had it too bad yet but I mean
excellent can get so badly a hands bleed
you know so we'll see I guess but
despite knowing that I was very stressed
all year I mean I was in and out of
police station a couple of times because
of something that happened and just a
lot of stuff I did not do anything
illegal for the record was about
something someone else did
just to clarify I knew that I was very
stressed I knew things were not great
last year but I didn't do anything about
it until October October was the point
where I was like it's probably a bit
much in it just probably need a chill
from all of this [ __ ] and naturally like
people have good years and bad years and
you don't know how long bad things are
going to happen for when they happen to
you you don't know how long you're going
to be stressful you don't expect it to
last as long as it does sometimes and I
feel like sometimes you can have a year
it seems like bad things are just piling
up on you and yeah so I finally did
decide to do something which was just
like very much take more time to just
chill I think I stopped streaming around
that time I made sure I went home for a
couple of weeks that was really
important to me and I think probably
helped me a lot coming into 2020
I definitely cut back on the amount of
YouTube videos I was making I made sure
I was working a lot less hours I was
sleeping more I just like end of October
it might have even actually been the
start of November just made the choice
to actually put myself before anything
else which can be very hard to do
because you always think you're gonna be
okay right
and I also fully recognize because this
will totally get pointed out in the
comments that my life is awesome like
there are a lot of just insanely cool
opportunities that I get and really cool
things that I get to do but the world
doesn't stop for that that doesn't stop
family members from having cancer scares
I didn't stop my granddad from dying
that didn't stop my mom from having to
get emergency surgery
you know like and those are just the
things I'm willing to talk about it
basically just you know yeah yes I'm
very grateful for how cool my life is
but it just over a period of time some
[ __ ] stacked up so October I finally
made the choice to just chill the [ __ ]
out and I feel like that was especially
hard for me because well I had to
recognize that I was just getting bad at
doing things anyway because I was
overworking myself and I feel like it's
a really important note what you think
will produce good results for you in
whatever it is that you're trying to do
whether it be professionally or even
personally or relationship-wise you
think that hard work will accomplish
anything I feel like that's what you're
told from the ground up as part of the
American dream even is just work hard
and you can do whatever you want and I
think I sort of realized recently that
that's false all that hard work involves
also working hard on yourself it is very
important to get as much sleep as you
need it's important to eat well it's
important to exercise it's important to
have downtime or you're not constantly
stressed
that's what yields positive results not
just hard work because if all you're
doing is working
you'll [ __ ] fall apart I see the
consequences on my goddamn hands with
this new [ __ ] thing I have to deal
with because I just kept trying to push
through something that I could not push
through that was just making me fail
that was that then every time that I
would fail I would be like I need to
walk caught up but you there's only so
much you can do when you're fainting and
naturally that that specific thing is
very personal to me but I just kind of
wanted to make this video to say
recognize stress stress is absolutely a
real thing and you can be a person who
like me was like I don't really get
stressed I'm fine
but if there are a lot of problems you
have stacked in your head and you're
thinking about them you probably are
stressed even if you don't I would
outwardly feel like that's the thing you
identify with if that makes sense
you have to learn how to tell what your
stress
feels like so I figured it out and like
I said finally took the time to take a
step back and and focus on me a little
bit more you know like I I intentionally
made sure I didn't have much work to do
while I was home in Australia except I
did have to edit a podcast but otherwise
just took a break that of course is a
luxury not everyone can afford but
ultimately I think I did it too late
I literally developed eczema because I
was so stressed here we are and I'm not
a psychologist I can't tell you how to
deal with your anxiety or deal with
stress I only know how I figured out how
to do it and that is paying attention to
it and paying attention to what makes me
feel better or at least what relaxes me
and I guess I'm very glad that I did but
it took you know several wake-up calls
before I could do that so what I want to
impart to everyone is just put time into
valuing yourself recognize what you as a
human need both mentally and physically
don't go to work if you sick someone
might be mad at you that's a reality but
it is better to have someone be mad at
you and to talk about to get anxious
about that happening than it is to make
yourself was consistently over and over
again for the rest of your goddamn life
because I feel like once you start
ignoring how you feel once you're just
gonna do it forever you're gonna put a
corporate system ahead of you or you're
gonna put some obligation that isn't
that important ahead of you and it'll
come to bite you in the ass
recognize that without your own sanity
and health long-term you're not going to
be able to do any of the things you were
trying to do anyway and if you're
stressed you're not going to do them to
the best of your ability anyway why burn
yourself out to fail when you could
maybe do things slower and achieve a lot
more because trust me I never thought
that I would end up [ __ ] expa it's
not the end of the world
you know it's not like terrible
debilitating illness but it's still like
I just a [ __ ] bomb up come on
it sucks and there are plenty worse
things that you can get as a result of
being stressed you won't live as long
and the same goes with diet and exercise
I know that like it's not cool to talk
about diet and exercise
it's cool to be like yeah man ate pizza
on the couch this weekend I don't know
what that was but I am I am gonna tell
you that treating your body with respect
in a way that is about you know focusing
on your own strengthen and physical
fitness rather than sitting on the couch
and eating pizza every night you can do
that some nights I'm not telling you not
to do it at all
give yourself a balance get nutrients
treat your body correctly and if you do
that even 50% of the week then it pays
off for 50% of your life or more
probably you need fuel to function
correctly and I just I don't know I feel
like this is very rambling I just feel
like I've wanted to say something I want
to say I feel like we are especially
unkind to ourselves lately I feel like
social media has to contribute to that
and the overuse of it and the
competition of it like for every hour
you spend arguing with people on the
internet that's an hour you could have
spent doing something you enjoy you know
and yes argument people on the internet
is addictive that's the problem but
addictive doesn't mean good for you
I don't know I'm just here to say look
after yourselves put yourself first
sometimes at least and take the science
seriously rather than acting like you
know the things that happen to other
people that haven't much worse to other
people could never happen to you because
of course they can and we'd be great if
we all had high immune systems before
the pandemic hits so there's that - all
right I don't know I hope this is like
remotely helpful I don't know I don't
know what I'm doing I just want people
to be nicer to themselves cuz I was a
[ __ ] to myself when I was having a tough
time and it only made it was for sure I
made it worse I needed to just chill out
and I refused and it's it's my own fault
I don't to myself nobody else did this
to me I did it I can't blame other
people for how stressed I got I can
blame other people for doing shitty
things or like not recognizing that I
was like very physically incapable of
doing what I was trying to do I guess
or not giving me the leeway with that I
guess but for the most part it's on me
and it has to be on
and you to recognize yourself and put
yourself first and recognize your own
value at the end of the day all you have
is you so treat you well okay that's it
I don't want I'll see you guys next time
bye